[Music]
remember that the devil day the attack
wall more than 50 million people have
watched that online and now the people
behind that classic prank have a new
scare with a very familiar ring to it
if you like devil baby hold on to your
diapers because the company behind it is
working it's black magic again this time
for the latest terrifying installment of
the ring for its latest viral video gag
the marketing agency think moto took
over a TV store in New York and got to
work rigging one particular screen to be
just a little too lifelike one of those
TVs we rigged so the one that TV moves
up and we distract people to look to the
side it reveals the actual character
from the movie whose image is being
played on all the other TVs at the same
time so the first TV I will show you
guys over here some cases people
reactive it laughter but it was really
nervous laughter others ran out the door
and we had to rein them in this viral
video campaign is just the latest bound
for marketing glory by the end of the
very first day of 130 million Facebook
views now the video is up to 200 million
in fact they're on track to surpass the
ridiculous success think moto had
promoting Devils due back into
14 before that they created huge buzz
for the remake of Carrie get away from
me and if past is prologue you're going
to be seeing this rings viral video
everywhere the actual film hits theaters
February 3rd
[Music]
you